let's let's take it to the biden family
before we get into the nuclear war stuff
we got this from uh real clear politics
average
joe biden's aggregate approval rating
hit a new record low today at 37.7
this is the aggregate this is not one
biased poll this is all of them
and
new york times released a poll with
biden at 33 percent
i mean even before he started screwing
up as president i remember
when the primaries were happening and i
was like there's no way no one's going
to vote for this guy this isn't
happening and then he just finally at
the number of who voted for him
they finally did accurate math yeah 37.7
do you think that if he came out and was
like okay everybody it's true hunter has
a problem i put him on there i just laid
it all out i i sent him where he needs
to go that that it would make it worse
for him it would so he's lying so he has
to lie i would respect him he has a
problem we put him into treatment like i
don't know most people that's the wrong
focal point yeah that's why i'm like you
know i would i wouldn't be surprised if
the psyop is leaking these images of
hunter to stop us from talking about
cynopec or or the the emails
the let's just say the business dealings
from hunter joe and hunter's business
partners the photographs
yeah all of a sudden everyone's like oh
look at hunter naked and it's like he's
got an email where he's talking about
you know
10 for the big guy and stuff like that
well i mean
it worked on me that was the joke i made
earlier where it's like why would you
make the delinquent kid in charge of all
this stuff so like
if it is that it worked
he put him on a board of an oil company
a ukrainian oil company well well he put
him there he didn't put him there let's
just say
the assumption would be
what we know is that hunter biden along
with i think like former c.i.a of course
was on the board of barisma yeah
uh joe biden
just so happened to um
push a quid pro quo with the president
of ukraine to fire a prosecutor who just
so happened to be investigating the
company whereas someone's a board member
it's all coincidence mind you because
joe said he didn't even talk to hunter
about any of his business dealings i
mean except for that one time they're in
a photo together with all of his
business partners and that other time
that he left a voicemail for his son
about his chinese business dealings yeah
tim god works in mysterious ways yeah
well yeah i mean it's also enron got a
new vp the last week and he was like wow
and i thought he'd be stuck in the mail
room all these years
that's good
so
i don't think here's a scary thought
joe biden what's that what's happening
now with the biden family with joe with
with gas with sending a million barrels
sign a pack that's really bad but will
it matter in two years
will people remember nah joe biden will
come out in it'll be two years and the
new cycle will be like joe biden farted
again mm-hmm
yeah and well in two years yeah that'll
be about it
i don't think he'll be able to do much
else he'll be like he
it's
almost a flat line
pretty much
i can't personally let go of the
surrender the afghanistan surrender that
one drives you nuts he left all this
eight billion dollars worth of equipment
i'm with you how many tens of thousands
of people to die with their babies like
to die to the taliban getting their
heads blown off like in in plain sight
of people that are right behind the wall
like watching it happen because he took
all the he he he evacuated and routed
the troop it's i think i think it was
punishment yeah but i think he was
punishing the antichrist look what a bad
choice trump made by saying we're gonna
be out on that day everyone see what
happens when you pull out on that day
but like you don't have to pull out on
the day you say you're gonna pull out on
if you're not ready you don't do it
right and so did obama i mean he said he
was gonna do that too and it's like when
you look at it he pulled it out and it's
like you left
military dogs alone made me angry but
then you left look at all the equipment
look at all the people that you left
behind that's what pissed me off about
all of it it's like then you come back
and you're going to start what having
the irs dig through a bunch of people's
taxes who legitimately paid make
arbitrary rules and start taking more
money from them while printing money
while you leave billions of dollars of
our equipment over there yeah like
everything about it makes me absolutely
sick yeah everything's right about this
i think this is the perfect distraction
because you just pull all the attention
away from stuff that's actually
legitimately concerned absolutely like
afghanistan for one there's so many
other disasters going on right now and
all we're doing is talking about hunter
biden being a crackhead which and yeah
and again like in all seriousness i like
addiction is horrible could you could
you imagine that they're like
these like psyops people walk into the
situation room with uh with joe and it's
like this is really bad for you mr
president this afghanistan stuff what
can we do and then like we have one
proposal sir we need to get hunter more
crack he's like
let's leak it to the press
one of hunters just is like great dude
desperately trying to get sober and he's
just like no i'm working on myself i
found buddhism i'm meditating and
they're just slipping him over and uh
your country needs you son and all of a
sudden uh okay then all of a sudden
hunter comes out from under the desk and
it's like i'm working on it
[Laughter]
oh man he wasn't if he wasn't put on the
board of barisma or if he didn't make
his way up to the board of barisma
somehow i wouldn't be concerned with his
activities i really wouldn't care no no
he's just a family
yeah but that joe has been working with
them so intricately and the guys you
know
naked with prostitutes
do we do we have to worry about
you know i know a lot of people like to
say oh i don't i don't care to talk
about the trump family and they're not
in office right now but it's assumed
within the fall trump is going to
announce he's running maybe he just
unveiled the rent the newly renovated
modernized 757 yeah he's going to be
running all the people we've had on the
show who who worked with trump have said
he's going to be running
is there any fair criticism of his
family are we overlooking anything with
with with trump jr now i'll be i'll be
right off the bat i'm pretty sure none
of them are doing crack or transporting
process or anything close to that if
there's anything close to that it would
be every major story every major
headline but my question is more so the
more important things like business
dealings yes
like so uh the only thing that i saw
that really like caught my eye was that
ivanka trump supposedly used sweatshop
labor which i know beyonce does as well
so it's not really a fair
shot well so she's basically like
beyonce then yeah that's a good thing
yeah that's great yeah but it's hard not
to be involved with it that's glamorous
like if you use teespring to sell your
t-shirts they're probably sourcing them
from chinese sweatshops right hey we
used these yeah i know yeah hey welcome
to welcome to the fascist reality no i
think it's
sorry that you're perfect little fingers
can make a great shirt
yeah look i got these these these
hands with calluses from playing the
guitar i couldn't i don't know i don't
know where your teeth are
i can't make nikes this young boy can
he's very talented
that's the argument is that they're
better off getting 25 cents per day than
not having jobs at all i mean which is
like the craziest that's the worst i
mean that's what you told me when you
hired me it's like
it's so funny because it's like no no
they're chilling
it's like no they're children they're
better off not having jobs at all yeah
they're better off playing yeah i think
kids need jobs i think kids need jobs i
think i like like allowance jobs
no but i mean like family business jobs
yeah you know like take out the trash
that's what i do with my son yeah yeah
but like um
it used to be great when kids would work
with dad but not to the extent where
they're like in a factory sewing
industrial level or
yeah they're not
like you would hold the flashlight for
your dad not actually build a car
exactly exactly yeah but you know um
being an assistant an apprentice uh uh
doing like you know my family at a cafe
so taking out the trash and ringing
people up and stuff that's the kind of
job kids needs it looks like teespring
may actually not use slave labor uh but
they they ship from the eu if you're
ordering internationally and then from
kentucky if you're ordering domestically
shout out to teespring
well i got a problem with those filthy
europeans so i actually i'm gonna go
back to the chinese slave way it's
actually my shirt it's young european
pickpockets
[Laughter]
i actually i had a guy try romney when i
was in barcelona seriously
yeah he was acting drunk barcelona and
he was like putting his arm around me
and i was pushing him off and he was
like oh come on come on and then he
grabbed my phone was on a clip on my bag
because i was working he grabbed it and
pulled and then i swat him away and he
didn't get it and then he went
pointed at me and then sobered up like
that just walked off wow because he knew
he lost it he knew like he has one
chance to pretend like he wasn't causing
problems
but i like that he just ended it by
being like well played and just dipped
off into the night
i mean he just could my phone was on a
clip and he grabbed it and pulled and it
was stuck to my back yeah i was like get
pull harder i don't know
well as i'm reading more about teespring
oh no people are saying they don't know
teespring doesn't disclose where they
actually produce their stuff the next
one is just puppy fur being made into
sure
i'll be looking into this as the days
they throw puppies into a grinder yeah
yeah
yes i gotta admit i was way off
don't eat items
now you're ragging on items no i'm only
doing that because they did stuff too
yeah
yeah i don't know what the it was knows
what puppies like they
recycling puppies yeah it was bad it
wasn't they did bad things yeah i don't
buy i don't buy their brand sure baby
they were serving dog meat secretly yeah
i think yeah or like testing the meats
in ways that were just horrible like i
remember seeing a lot of like yeah
beagles like stacked on top of each
other which could have just been
fouchy's house
but there weren't a lot of flies
i want to go back and mention you know
we talk about like the trump family you
know i mentioned it because they're
probably gonna be running but you look
at how they go after like baron remember
remember when they act that was attacked
him for his name yeah things like that
he's like a teenager and for being
special needs oh yeah
isn't he i don't know he's a little
hustler he's slightly autistic yeah a
math genius or something yeah that was
always like yeah that's what a horrible
number one that would have been really
funny if you were trying to defend him
and you're like when they went after him
for being special needs he's not special
needs oh well i thought he was oh i feel
for baron the whole time i kind of felt
like that was happening right now
remember when
they they ran this big story claiming
that don jr had privy access to
wikileaks oh really and then it turned
yeah and then trying to be fake they
were like
the email that he sent about wikileaks
came like well after wikileaks had
already published a bunch of stuff and
they're trying to make it seem like they
were colluding with russia i mean i'll
do my
patented tim cast old liberal confession
where i never read stories on the trump
kids but just from the headlines i would
see or the way people would talk about
them i totally just assumed they were
just these like privileged drug addicts
i kind of assumed they were the same as
like similar to like hunter biden types
and i don't yeah i didn't know anything
i don't know meanwhile don junior's out
there handing cans of soup to the home
right i certainly didn't see that story
yeah i don't know if he's actually doing
that either but you know who's like
hunter biden though is nancy pelosi's
son paul pelosi jr he has a wild history
too he's not as bad a drug drug addict
but he's every bit as corrupt i think he
needs his patsy too his dad drove drunk
yep was it is his father that was that
was recently right yeah well yeah his
wife wanted to have sex and
just drove into a jeep
okay all right you you this is your
fault
you opened the door
in the court of tim cass and now i got
to mention that photo of nancy pelosi
that went viral oh no why would you do
that oh i photoshopped it with my face
on it oh god
my friend ellie did one of my friends
texted it to me and goes uh jamie's
about to become a neolib and i like open
it i was like oh no
okay for those that don't know it it was
nancy pelosi going to the beach
and
good for her bazongas would be the
cartoon word i would use
massive i was stunned i mean who tweeted
like i'm ashamed at how i feel right
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i just did it
i was like i'm not i don't i that is i
feel like all the pills she takes go
right to her breasts
i'm still depressed but these are huge
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you